تزامنا مع القذف الاوكراني على مدينه
دانيت وضواحيها توجهنا الى بلده
الكسندراكا التي يسيطر عليها الجيش الروسي
شمال غربي المقاطعه ما زالت البلده تتعرض
لقصف عنيف وبقي فيها قليل من السكان
قريه الكسندرا المتاخمه لمدينه مارينكا
حيث المعارك الساخنه المستمره حيث يستمر
الجيش الروسي بمواصله اعماله العسكريه رغم
سقوط القذائف والصواريخ على مناطق المدنيه
تعاني من اعاقه بساقها حدثتنا عن معاناتها
بعد تعرض بيتها للقصف واستغياب زوجها
سقطت في المنزل فتصلت بوالدي مباشره
الى انعدام الغاز ذلك ما جعل ما فات الحطب
صانعه الدفء والطعام في هذا المكان
في العصر الحجري وانا احضر الطعام من لا
شيء على الحطب هذه الاواني
الفضائح
ما كان اقامه الجيش الروسي ونقطه انطلاقه
لمواجهه الجيش الاوكراني في مدينه مارينكا
المتاخمه لها ذلك ما يجعلها دائما في مرمى
نيران القوات الاوكرانيه دخلنا الى احدى
السكنات العسكريه لنسمع من الجنود عن
احوال المعارك في هذه المنطقه همم
والحمد لله ليس لدينا قتله حتى الان
من هذا المكان وعلى بعد عشرات الامطار ما
زالت الاله العسكريه الروسيه تقصف
بالمدافع وراجمات الصواريخ مواقع الجيش
الاوكرانيه التي ما زالت مركز في اخر
المدينه
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاخضر
اواخر مارينكا مقاطعه دانيت